As like any e-commerce
company should do, we
constantly optimize the conversion rates
as we think about the purchase flow.
In traditional e-commerce, when you
have a visitor come to your page, and
a visitor actually checking out, it's
just a really big drop-off anywhere from
90% to 98% depending on
the e-commerce site.
This is because there's a lot
of different barriers in
that process as you're
trying to understand
what type of product do I want,
what type of color, what type of size,
now I have to put in all my address
information and payment information.
We constantly try to optimize
that experience to make it as
easy as possible and making it as few
clicks and things people are typing in.
An example of that was as we
are thinking about, we have
people coming into Teespring and they
have already purchased from us before.
What is a way we can make
that process easier for
them to actually be able to then import
all their previous address information?.
This was a feature which
we hadn't ever built prior.
As we looked at this, one of the things
that we really wanted to optimize for
was around speed and especially for
people on their devices,
like on their phones being able to type
in a lot of fields is really painful.
That's just one example of how
we tried to optimize for this,
is to say that if you're a buyer
who's come to Teespring before,
what are the different
ways that we can actually
import your previous information
into the checkout experience?